a subtropical storm pushing towards
Florida could become the first named
storm of this hurricane season the
system is already bringing heavy rain
and powerful winds in the southeast in
the Northeast
more than 30,000 customers were without
power Friday night after a severe
thunderstorm knocked down trees and
power lines in Massachusetts so far
there have been no confirmed reports of
tornadoes and in Texas severe weather is
threatening to bring more torrential
rain some drivers were stuck for hours
in floodwaters near Houston on Friday
meteorologist Jeff beard le has more on
the nation's weather Jeff good morning
good morning Dana and good morning
everybody
well we're 15 days out from the official
start of hurricane season and believe it
or not we're gonna have yet another
tropical system and when I say that I
mean we've seen one before June first
the last six consecutive seasons right
now the system is located just to the
east of Florida and that system is going
to be taking shape during the day today
and moving northeastward here's what's
gonna happen the storm is going to move
up the eastern seaboard probably just
offshore but there's another big storm
that's going to emerge out of the
Midwest and try to capture it if it's
able to capture it our American model
says it's possible it may move right up
the eastern seaboard the European model
kicks it out to see we're not exactly
sure but one of the scenarios is that
the Middle Atlantic could end up with
some wind gusts over 40 miles an hour as
we head into Tuesday and also some
really large waves possibly up to 15 20
foot waves offshore that means rough
surf and maybe some minor coastal
flooding so watch out over the next
couple of days the other big story is
what's happening Texas and Louisiana we
showed you the video of Louisiana with a
lot of flooding there well unfortunately
very heavy rain is likely during the day
today along the Texas Gulf Coast as
humidity pours its way north that means
2 to 4 in some places seeing as much as
five inches of rain it's an active
weather pattern have a great weekend
everybody yeah way too early for
Hurricane Jeff thank you